holy
oh my God
[Music]
hey guys looks like Jersey Shore family
vacations about two
with the return of Sammy sweetheart is
this real are you a hologram is this AI
yep the reality star shocks her OG
co-stars with an appearance on the MTV
reboots season 6 finale
holy
oh my God
sure
hey guys sorry I'm late
and let's just say she comes back with a
bang
a musty coming for me now can you let me
stop
no you talk so much
just shut up it was a wild ride it
definitely was but I'm still the
sweetest bed she'll ever meet
in March Sammy teased her big return on
Instagram sharing a behind the scenes
snap on set writing okay I can finally
say I'm back
Sammy was the only original member who
decided not to join in on the vacay fund
when the Jersey Shore spin-off began
filming back in 2018. she chose to move
on in a chapter in her life where it did
not choose Jersey Shore and at the time
she explained I am not the same person
as I was when I was 22 and she wanted to
avoid quote toxic situations we all
support her as a group and whatever
makes her happy makes her happy you know
I can't judge her for still the cast
went to Great Lengths to include her in
some way or another
[Music]
I hate you I get Paulie wanted to bring
this new Sammy in as like oh
is with us and this is great and the
entire family's here she gets the joke
yeah she's she's she knows it was all in
good fun yeah I'm glad too because I was
like shoot I hope she doesn't hate me
you know she's a good sport she said I
would stick up for her like this was
gonna happen I feel like if Sam would
have came it would have been more
positive for her it was important to me
because I would hope if I wasn't in the
house she would do the same for me and I
really think she would
um and I told her like I wasn't going to
let anybody really talk bad about her
and she's fine she she thinks the whole
thing was funny she doesn't care and
five years later the gang's all back
together again
holy
oh my God
[Music]
hey guys sorry I'm late
what the
this time around the past couple years
we've just gotten closer and we really
support each other in everything that we
do we really are that close
[Music]
thank you